[Music]
stealing from the needy news Oh tacos
three officers have been accused of
stealing an odd toiletry item from a
homeless shelter those wax liner things
that David this is here for you yeah the
liner for the toilet will they see Club
Rossi covers dispenser a dispenser navel
just comes into the box
your pump but you but yeah no soap is in
it she said I need one of those for my
house but the thing that holds the
toilet roll no no this is it a homeless
place right so it's gotta be like
sanitizer or some [ __ ] right like this
hold it people dirty it good yeah why
this is so [ __ ] dirty that I mean
they need to clean themselves all them
constantly yeah I need a sanitizer
dispenser a little tube that's why cover
for the gas and they got light bulbs
light bulbs no I don't know I don't
think did they give those it's not a
toiletry items will they have them on
toilet rambabu but lupus no no nothing
as shards do
shower cap no Roach traps
that's toiletries that was my next guy
good be the bathroom no so it was hair
removal Oh Oh like Mayer on there and
beets so this is their do people still
use their and this is the baby question
so these weren't used homeless people
they use it for torture items against
people there they arrested huh why the
cops so there were these three cops that
went to this women's shelter in Brooklyn
and they were seen taking away boxes of
beat and there and there was this fourth
identified person involved but they went
AWOL and they haven't shown up to work
and so now they're just saying like he's
so good very makable news right and
these acts are just respectful like how
could these peace officers that come
like I guess they were describing ones
peace officers how could they be doing
that to the people that they're supposed
to be helping because so the reason why
they had these Nair and hair removal is
so they don't use razors because all you
do is like you put it on you wait a
certain amount of time and it burns the
hair off you wipe it off and so they
were saying but then the officers
involved they were saying that well we
heard that all these items were gonna be
thrown in the trash because they
couldn't use it for some reason and then
so we didn't want them to go in the
trash lit so we were gonna use it for
ourselves but then the people in the
shelter were like no we bought them
specifically for the women in the
shelter I just picture three hairy
Italian cops and it comes in video
anyway there's an East Coast right they
can't afford to get their own beats
right but they were saying like from
there I got real hairy [ __ ] you
wanna I don't want it to be going to
waste the trash that wasn't in the trash
not scored each other's [ __ ] of the
Narron [ __ ] I'm very very proud of the
company there because I remember Nair
was on those infomercials yeah I was
like Proactiv it was like yeah it was
like one of those things but now they're
such a regular commodity in stores now
that's how amazing that company here
burnt the [ __ ]
my upper lip me too really in effect so
long ago school and I psyche I get was
too embarrassed to tell him that I was
trying to get rid of my mustache guys
that it was a cold sores you have a
mustache all right it's not I have AIDS
it was like because what cold sores here
isn't that the same as isn't that the
same as herpes it's cold sorry it's a
it's a type of herpes so it's like I've
never had a cold sore II just was like
oh and looks like one it's a cold sore
my friend bought in there to kind of
like hook up his legs and shake his yet
really furry legs and then so we did one
patch and just [ __ ] try to spray that
off and I think it comes with a kit
right there's like a wack snare and then
there's like a sprain err
I just used the the chemical and the
chemical as a chemical burn so you're
not supposed to rub it at all and you're
supposed to just press and then wipe but
like if you left it on too long or if
you put too much pressure on it it like
burns all of your skin oh yeah he ended
up with this big patch of like Bert and
then he didn't want to use any more of
it yeah puss his up and that's why she
said it was a cold sore cuz it like
buses up and then scabs over it well
that's why when people say like yo no
more animal testing that's [ __ ] up I'm
like dude that's how we found out about
an air burning your lip and you still
like are you crazy
do you still have a mustache well
everyone has like a mustache after that
my upper lip got so sent so desensitized
that I just pluck it out and I don't
even feel the hairs anymore hmm just get
it called Lady Bird no lasering your
face isn't good they told me that if cuz
I ain't looking to a two but they were
like no it's not good good scar it's
well they said that it activates another
hair follicles in your face and you
could get hair like so far in places
that sounds like a lazy person doesn't
do the job the nurse told me that
cuz they have a nurse that you consult
with first before you it's kind of weird
though like when I see older women who
have like full-on like facial hair yeah
you get when women like whiskers yeah
dude saw in Hawaii with a bunch of those
older people just ladies with like
whiskers everywhere on their face I've
never been here sorcery store without
seeing a woman with a mustache there you
go hasn't happened yeah at least walk
they just give up maybe yeah I mean at
that point I'm really forget please
don't
Jesus all right cause like yesterday
good goes down that's true yeah we do
went through menopause and stuff but I
want you to be 55 with a fu-manchu's
whatever whenever menopause is guys they
change they can't be older older oh the
grandmas
like turn into like super aggressive and
then like the grandpa's like chill the
hell out Marilyn I saw this [ __ ] cute
ass thing happened when we were in
Hawaii there was this older white lady
like she was like from one of like the
mental states and she's just asking
everybody what they show well what did
what did you get to eat super [ __ ]
cute right mm-hmm
but it's so funny how like siblings can
still fight each other the same way they
did when they're younger no matter how
old they are so her sister was cutting
my purse and they're both really old and
she goes what took you so long
what were you by she goes it's none of
your business till got it you know
that's so [ __ ] bickering with each
other I thought I remember reading some
headline or something or on YouTube or I
don't know there's these two really old
oh yeah it reminded me and I watch them
non-stop it's grandma and Doc Gemma or
something like that but there's their
siblings yeah just like she was like all
your dumb asses [ __ ] she goes yeah
because like sailors [ __ ] there's
that one Italian grandmothers trying to
use Google home
googoo right she's [ __ ] oh yeah
Bumi study found a lady who used to do
depression-era cooking oh yeah so she
was from the Great Depression she's like
here's some some meals we used to make
during the Depression and she would like
make like sardines or whatever [ __ ] and
then use paper and water yeah it was
like some thrifty [ __ ] right and some
good-looking [ __ ] but I went and then I
found her nose oh this is really fun and
then I went to her most current video
and it was just and I was like oh [ __ ]
this was two years ago and then and then
I saw the video of like in memoriam and
I was like damn I just found her I just
been on I liked her and I find out that
she's dead at the same time that's so
sad that there was there's a Japanese
cooking show called cooking with dog
glad dog died [ __ ] rekt me dude I was
so sad if you think it has many views
anymore yeah get another dog well they
have like a stuffed animal now or
something like that oh she wanted see
stuff the dog walking dog was the
perfect dog on earth just set yeah she
would cook and in a dog would just sit
the whole so it's not the same anymore
cuz a stoic dog is not sitting there
washing things down the channel is
called cooking with dog I get it but
like I get why they did a stuffed animal
and you hacks can't watch it anymore
that's amazing
she seems sad her - that's what she
definitely I mean they she took a break
after the dog passed away I think it was
pretty traumatic on her but then I still
watch that cuz she does really great
like home cooking Japanese it's not like
that fancy stuff you see in restaurants
but it's like stuff that you see like in
like Japanese home stuff so [ __ ] love
that Keane was good enough and they had
that weird nasally Japanese man doing
the voice-over that's probably her
husband yeah sorry the voice already man
like he would voice over whatever she's
doing yeah because she doesn't speak
English but he does or whatever and you
have this accent today we are cooking
with dog yeah oh sweet so it's like Iron
Chef when you're watching that show and
they're telling you what's going on yeah
that's great fast that you want to put
the two eggs
sounds Italian all of a sudden here yeah
we were talking about these police
officers stealing from the
oh yeah
classic I hope they can chemically
burned by that
oh that's a good JK response okay okay
what if what if it wasn't police
officers what if it was just regular
sick orphans then it would be fine right
okay so it depends on them because
they're equal or hairy orphans
the thing is that they're stealing from
the needy but if a needy was stealing
from the needy they're all needy there
was a woman's women's women's shelter
steals from very rich billionaires then
it makes people feel good see if my
thing is still stealing hair removal
from the needy is not that primal so I'm
not as like Oh like if it's food I'm
like yo yeah but it's like hey we stole
hair removal kits that's why those
kempelen's or something yeah I was like
we stole hair dye oh my god okay that's
something it's wrong it's a luxury yeah
it's not it's like not the nation that
luxuries I wouldn't want the shelter to
steal from billionaires because we need
them to be the heroes like we don't want
them to steal like be bad yeah okay how
do you feel about robbing has been well
he would steal from the rich to the
point he was a middleman he was the
middleman
yeah but the poor didn't steal from the
rich he stole from the rich gave to the
poor so if someone stole from the rich
and gave to the shelter Robin Hood is a
criminal and he should be locked up
you're the Sheriff of Nottingham that's
right I actually think then he Robin
Hood was a criminal he was a couple yeah
it was a Crim right so just because the
technically he's a criminal doesn't mean
I don't disagree I think if everyone was
given the opportunity to become rich
then he was a criminal but I don't think
in that time the serfs or the peasants
or whatever could had the opportunities
to start to become rich so being tagged
yeah they were taxed like crazy you have
a does anybody ever thought about the
Kings feelings and how stressful it is
from our whole kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]